INSTITUTION FRANKLY.
>> Laura: FANTASTIC PANEL.
A RELATED DEVELOPMENT RUDY
GIULIANI NOW HAS CONFIRMED
THAT HE HAS JOINED TRUMP'S
LEGAL TEAM TO NEGOTIATE THE
END OF SPECIAL COUNSEL BOB
MUELLER'S PROBE.
GOOD LUCK.
RUDY GIULIANI APPARENTLY IS
LOOKING TO USE HIS PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP TO MUELLER TO
SMOOTH THINGS OVER.
OKAY.
JOINING US NOW IS SOMEONE
WHO ALSO KNOWS BOB MUELLER
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL MIKE
MUKASEY WHO HELD THAT
POSITION WHICH MUELLER WAS
FBI DIRECTOR.
GENERAL MUKASEY, JUDGE
MUKASEY, YOU WERE ON RADIO
WITH ME THIS MORNING AND ON
TV TONIGHT.
IT'S LIKE WE ARE PLAYING THE
WHOLE DAY TODAY, I LOVE IT?
>> ME TOO.
>> Laura: JUDGE, LET'S TALK
ABOUT THIS WILD DAY.
NOW WE HAVE AN INVESTIGATION
GOING ON AT THE IG, A
CRIMINAL REFERRAL OF ANDREW
MCCABE WHO IS, OF COURSE,
COMEY'S DEPUTY.
NOW THE INSURANCE
NOW THE INSPEANCE
NOW THE INSPECTCE
NOW THE INSPECTOR GENERAL IS
INVESTIGATING WHETHER COMEY
KNEW SOME OF THIS
INFORMATION WAS CLASSIFIED
WHEN HE TRANSMITTED IT TO
HIS PAL AT COLUMBIA.
YEAH, I THINK WE OUGHT TO
PUT TO REST ONE OF THE
THINGS ONE OF YOUR GUESTS
SAID IN THE LAST SEGMENT.
THE MOMMIES WEREN'T MARKED
CLASSIFIED AT THE TIME.
THEY WERE CLASSIFIED AS SOON
AS HE WROTE THEM.
I HAD AN EXPERIENCE WHEN I
STARTED AS AG ON TAKING
NOTES ON A TOP SECRET
PROCEDURE.
AND WHEN I GOT UP TO LEAVE
THE MEETING, MY CHEN CHIEF
OF STAFF LEANED OVER AND
WROTE TS/SCI.
TOP SECRET.
SECURE DEEMENT MENTAL.
THOSE WEREN'T MY NOTES THEY
WERE THE GOVERNMENT'S NOTES.
THEY WEREN'T COMEY'S MEMOS
THEY WERE THE GOVERNMENT'S
MEMOS.
IF THE INFORMATION IN THEM
WAS CLASSIFIED WAS
CLASSIFIED AS SOON AS THEY
PUT IT DOWN ON PAPER.
>> Laura: HE SAID THEY WERE
PERSONAL REFLECTIONS.
PERSONAL THOUGHTS AND
REFLECTS ON THE MEETING HE
HAD WITH THE PRESIDENT.
>> PERSONAL THOUGHTS AND
REFLECTIONS ARE FINE.
IF THEY WERE PERSONAL
THOUGHTS AND REFLECTIONS
ABOUT CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, THEN THEY ARE
CLASSIFIED.
PERSONAL THOUGHTS AND
REFLECTIONS.
YOU CAN'T SIMPLY TAKE THEM
OUT AND LEAK THEM.
>> Laura: JUDGE MUKASEY, YOU